so puttering coffee gym puttering coffee
gym and then work work so what's work
look like what what what do the
productive uh hours look like for you I
you know so I a couple years ago I left
as the CEO of Amazon and I have never
worked harder in my life
so I am I am working so hard and I'm
mostly enjoying it but there are also
some very painful days uh most of my
time is spent on um blue origin and I've
been I'm so deeply involved here now for
the last couple of years and in the big
I love it in the small there's all the
frustrations that come along with
everything you know we're trying to get
to rate manufacturing as we talked about
that's super important we'll get there
we just hire a new CEO guy I've known
for close to 15 years now a guy named
Dave limp who I love he's amazing you
know um so we're super lucky to have
Dave and you know we're going to you're
you're going to see us move faster there
but so my day of work you know reading
documents having meetings um sometimes
in person sometimes over Zoom depends on
where I am it's all about you know the
technology it's about the organization
it's about you know I'm very um I I
have architecture and Technology
meetings almost every day on various
subsystems inside the vehicle inside the
engines it's super fun for me my
favorite part of it is the
technology um my least favorite part of
it is you know building organizations
and so on that's important but it's also
my least favorite part so you know
that's why they call it work you don't
always get to do what you want to do how
do you achieve time where you can focus
and truly think through problems I do
little thinking Retreats so for this is
not the only I I can do that all day
long I'm very good at focusing I'm very
good at that um you know I'm I don't
keep to a strict schedule like my
meetings often go longer than I plan for
them to because I believe in wandering I
my perfect meeting starts with a crisp
document so the document should be
written with such Clarity that it's like
angels singing from on high I like a
crisp document and a messy meeting and
so the meeting is about like asking
questions that nobody knows the answer
to and and and and trying to like wander
your way to a solution and um uh cuz
like and that is if when that happens
just right it makes all the other
meetings worthwhile it feels good it has
has a kind of beauty to it it has an
aesthetic Beauty to it and and you get
real breakthroughs in meetings like that
can you actually describe the the crisp
document like this is one of the
legendary aspects of Amazon uh of the
way you approach meetings is the
six-page memo maybe first describe the
process of running a meeting with memos
and meetings at Amazon and blue origin
are unusual when we when we get new when
new people come in like a new executive
joins they're a little taken aback
sometimes because the typical meeting
will start with a six-page narratively
structured memo and we do study hall for
30 minutes we sit there silently
together the meeting and read take notes
in the
margins and then we then we discuss and
the Reason by the way we do stud you
could say I would like everybody to read
these memos in advance but the problem
is people don't have time to do that and
they end up coming to the meeting having
only skimmed the memo or maybe not read
it at all and they're trying to catch up
and they're also bluffing like they were
in college having pretended to do the
reading yeah exactly it's better just to
carve out the time for people so now we
all the same page we've all read the
memo and now we can have a really
elevated discussion and this is so much
better from having a slideshow
presentation you know a PowerPoint
presentation of some kind where there
that has so many difficulties but one of
the problems is Powerpoint is really
designed to persuade it's kind of a
sales tool and internally the last thing
you want to do is sell you want to again
you're truth seeking you're trying to
find truth and the other problem with
PowerPoint is it's easy for the author
and hard for the audience and a memo is
the opposite it's hard to write a six-
page memo a good six- page memo might
take two weeks to write you have to
write it you have to rewrite it you have
to edit it you have to talk to people
about it they have to poke holes in it
for you you write it again it may take
two weeks so the author it's really a
very difficult job but for the audience
it's much better so you can read a half
hour and you know there are little
problems with PowerPoint presentations
too you know senior Executives interrupt
with questions halfway through the
presentation that question is going to
be answered on the next slide but you
never got there whereas if you read the
whole memo in advance you you know I
often write lots of questions that I
have in the margins of these memos and
then I go cross them all out because by
the time I get to the end of the memo
they've been answered that's why I save
all that time you also get you know if
the person who's preparing memo we
talked earlier
about um you know group think and you
know the fact that I go last in meetings
and that you don't want you know to your
ideas to kind of pollute the meeting
prematurely um you know the author of
The memos is has has kind of got to be
very vulnerable they got to put all
their thoughts out there and they've got
to go first but that's great because it
makes them really good and so and you
get to see their real life ideas and
you're not trumpling on them
accidentally in a big you know
PowerPoint presentation what I feel like
when you've authored a thing and then
you're sitting there and everybody's
reading your thing you're like I think
it's mostly terrifying
yeah like maybe in a good way I think
it's a purifying I think it's terrifying
in a in a productive way yeah um but I
think it's emotionally a very
nerve-wracking experience is there a art
science to the writing of the six-page
memo or just writing in general to you
the I mean it's really got to be a real
memo so it means you know paragraphs
have topic sentences it's verbs and
nouns you can't that's the other problem
with PowerPoint pres there often just
bullet points and you can you can hide a
lot of sloppy thinking behind bullet
points when you have to write in
complete sentences with narrative
structure it's really hard to hide
sloppy thinking so it does it it forces
the author to be at their best and so
you're getting somebody's they're
getting somebody's really their best
thinking and then you don't have to
spend a lot of time trying to tease that
thinking out of the person and you've
got it from the very beginning so it
really saves you time in the long run uh
so that part is crisp and then the rest
is messy crisp doc yes and you don't
want you don't want to pretend that the
discussion should be crisp yeah there's
you know most meetings you're trying to
solve a really hard problem there's a
different kind of meeting which we call
weekly business reviews or business
reviews they may be weekly or monthly or
daily whatever they are but these
business review meetings that's usually
for incremental Improvement and you're
look looking at a series of metrics
every time it's the same metrics those
meetings can be very efficient they can
start on time and end on
time